what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have some
very interesting news about the
Fantastic Four specifically regarding
the casting of Reed Richards now the
casting of the Fantastic Four lately has
been a pretty big topic especially
before d23 because we definitely thought
that we were going to get the cast for
The Fantastic Four then however we
didn't but that does not stop the fact
that the Fantastic Four cast should be
pretty much made up already if not
Marvel Studios should be very very close
in their search to finding Reed Richards
Sue storm Ben Grimm and Johnny Storm now
we've heard many many different things
so far like pin Badgley is the front
runner to be Reed Richards of the MCU
and that Jody Comer from free guy is in
the running to be Sue storm and things
like Seth Rogen could even be playing
the thing but today we have some news
from some Insider accounts who are known
to be fairly accurate with their Scoops
we also have a tiny bit of news about
some possible X-Men castings and let's
start with that this is actually about
Giancarlo Esposito now if you're not
aware recently Giancarlo Esposito has
been pretty outspoken about the fact
that he would love to play Professor
Xavier in the MCU he's also been pretty
outspoken about the fact that he's
already met with Marvel Studios about
roles in the MCU well recently at a
Comic Con a fan saw him and held up a
Funko Pop of Professor Xavier in which
Giancarlo Esposito replied see you on
the big screen now of course this could
be a joke however we do know that he has
been pushing for this role and we do
know that he has met with Marvel Studios
and we also do know that he is pretty
outspoken normally I would say well an
actor wouldn't just say it like that he
wouldn't just reveal that he had been
cast for a role however he has spoken
out a lot about wanting to play that
role while at the same time these actors
are very aware of what fans talk about
and how things can spread pretty quick
quickly online especially through
YouTube channels like my own so I want
to say he was kidding but you never know
he really wants that role and he's met
with Marvel Studios so we'll have to
wait and see but in the meantime let me
know in the comments if you think he
would make a good Professor Xavier now
switching over to the Fantastic Four we
have some very interesting news about
the Fantastic Four from the account can
we get some toast the first report
States Fantastic Four scoop they're
looking at POC actors for read as well
some juicy actors in the running for it
outside of Adam Driver 2. now I should
state that before in the past there have
been reports that Marvel Studios has
been looking at some Star Wars actors
some pretty big known names and some
people right away automatically assumed
Adam Driver and John boyega especially
after people like Ewan McGregor said
that he's a part of the Star Wars
Universe he doesn't really need to be a
part of the MCU not that he doesn't like
it he's just a part of this really big
universe however for some of these
younger actors it's definitely only a
possibility and according to can we get
some toast Diego Luna is one of the
Front Runners to play Reed Richards in
the MCU now I really like Diego Luna I
actually really enjoyed the Andor series
and I think he's doing a fantastic job I
think he's a fantastic actor as well I
have nothing against him however I don't
think that he would make a perfect Reed
Richards would he do a good job yes I
firmly believe that he would do a good
job however I think somebody like John
Krasinski or even pin Badgley as a
younger read Richards would fit the role
a little bit more than he would although
right now it's kind of unknown on what
direction they're going to take the
Fantastic Four in what direction they're
going to take the individual characters
Kevin feige has already came out and
said that the Fantastic Four movie isn't
going to be a true origin story about
the team and right now the biggest rumor
is that Mr Fantastic Reed Richards could
even show up in Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania and if that is true that
means Marvel Studios has already cast
their actor for Reed Richards because
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania is done
filming sure they could do some reshoots
but we only have four months until the
movie comes out so if that is true we'll
see soon enough who our Reed Richards is
going to actually be but in the meantime
let me know what you think about this
recent report for Diego Luna being in
the run and also Adam Driver would you
like either of these two to play Reed
Richards and the Fantastic Four movie in
the MCU let me know all your thoughts in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all things MCU and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
foreign